foreign
we're going to be talking about the AI
war between Microsoft and Google last
week I did a video on chat gbt with a
high level overview of what's happening
but today in this video I'll go more in
depth about Microsoft and Google and why
I think they're making the moves they're
making all right before I go deep let's
go through a quick news recap that's
relevant to today's video a few weeks
ago Google launched Bard AI sorry I mean
Google announced that they will launch
Bard eventually to compete with chat gbt
you know Google tends to do a lot of
announcing but not a lot of shipping
however in the ad Bard made a mistake
which caused their stock price to tank
not the greatest first impression and
the product hasn't even launched yet
some googlers criticize them for trying
to launch this too quickly that they
rushed it not only did they make a
mistake in the ad during a demo in Paris
they weren't able to do the demo because
they forgot their phone they were going
to use to show off one of Bart's
features look at this clip let's see how
that works with a live demo
we are missing the
missing the phone
we will have to
we have no okay we're gonna move on we
can't find the phone sorry we'll do a
let one later in the special q a
how embarrassing the day after the
announcement Microsoft responded by
releasing a new Bing with chat GPT built
in to compete with Google's search for
context Google basically has a monopoly
on search with 93 of all search volumes
currently the three percent Bing
searches are probably from people with
new computers using Microsoft Edge to
search Google to get to google.com
you know I was initially joking but it
turns out it's actually true from this
article saying that Google is the most
searched word on Bing
but Jokes Aside Google needs to take
this threat seriously because it is not
just about search it's about the AI war
and this is just one of many battles for
Microsoft Bing is just another product
because Microsoft's revenue is very
Diversified if Microsoft was a YouTuber
it would look like this hey Microsoft
here today I'm going to show you how I
built 12 income streams in my 20s don't
forget to smash that like button and
turn your default search to Bing it
really helps with the algorithm all
right let's get to it for Google search
is their lifeblood in this situation
it's easier to attack than to defend
your market share since Bing can take
more risk and ship faster because it has
nothing to lose and by that I mean it
has no users to lose while Google has to
move slower not to risk its reputation
and lose their search users which is
their main source of Revenue not only is
Microsoft competing in search it's also
competing in web browsers by revamping
Microsoft Edge by integrating open aai's
Tech into it they call it your personal
co-pilot of the web sounds familiar
GitHub co-pilot helps you get your ideas
into code faster a web browser co-pilot
will help you read the web pages faster
with AI summarization draft emails
faster with AI generation and bully
people on Twitter faster with AI
suggested insults
this is their vision of what the next
era of the internet will look like an
internet browsing experience
personalized and assisted with AI and
whoever gets there faster wins the AI
War to explain this AI War here's an
analogy it's like a chess game between
team Microsoft and team Google the goal
is simple the Kings have to survive
Microsoft and Google are the Kings
because they have lots of money and fat
they move slowly and their only goal in
life is to not die if you've ever worked
at a big tech company you'd know that
things move very slowly because it's
filled with processes extensive reviews
and unproductive employees like I was so
they can't move as fast as a startup
that's why in order for big Tech to
survive they need to acquire or invest
in startups to hedge against new tech
that can potentially disrupt them and
cause them to fall behind which is why
Microsoft partnered with AI startup open
Ai and Google acquire deepmind and also
invested in entropic these companies are
the Queens not because they're fabulous
but because they can move really fast
and make breakthroughs in AI the king
relies on the queen to make strong moves
and win this war but she needs money
which is what the king is able to supply
but I ain't saying she's a gold digger
but she ain't messing with no broke tech
company
the king is also able to supply an army
of products and apps for the queen those
are the pawns and each of them are in a
proxy battle against each other like
Chachi pity against Bard and Bing
against Google search winning these
battles is important because your pawns
can get promoted into stronger pieces
like a rook and by that I mean you
dominate in one vertical and you start
snowballing to illustrate let's say your
product is used by more users so you get
more data and since you have more data
you can fine tune your model better so
your product gets better and since your
product is better then you're gonna keep
getting more users it's a winner takes
all market and once this flywheel starts
it's hard to compete because you have
proprietary user data and a well-trained
model creating this barrier of Entry
that gets thicker and thicker for
newcomers that in turn will feed into
your queen to help its research to reach
more AI breakthroughs which will further
feed into your Suite of products to
summarize the King give it's the queen
money and an army of products the queen
backs up the products with the latest AI
Tech the pawns will give user data back
to the queen so that the queen can
improve the AI the pawns also give
Revenue back to the king so that the
king can reinvest in itself now the
advancement of the pawns is key to
winning this war hence winning these
proxy battles is helpful for winning the
real battle which is who can achieve
more algorithmic breakthroughs in AI or
even reach AGI artificial general
intelligence if that happens all the
pawns will become queens and your window
War or the queen will just revolt and
kill their kings and actually kill all
their pawns too and the chessboard and
me
singularity
anyways in Tech there's no such thing as
too big to fail in fact you're more at
risk when you've grown too big even
small decisions start to take forever to
get the company aligned and execute on
them so one solution is to acquire these
startups and slowly move into a desired
location for the company that's why you
see big tech companies constantly
acquiring startups to hedge against
their downfall like Facebook buying
Instagram for one billion dollars to
solidify their lead in social media
Amazon acquiring Whole Foods to solidify
their lead in delivering everything to
you so you never need to leave your
house
right now the biggest threat to these
big tech companies is falling behind in
AI let me tell you a cautionary tell of
a big tech company once valued at 125
billion dollars that ended up selling
for just 4.8 billion dollars that
company was Yahoo
or more like Yahoo
all right let's go back to dial up
internet era the time when if you were
connected to the internet you couldn't
use your phone at home remember this
sick ass tune
back in 1995 Yahoo was a beast at first
it was just a web directory of other
websites organized in a hierarchy that's
how we used to organize the web then
Yahoo also became the main search engine
people use it was called Yahoo search
back then people used to go to these web
portals as their first destination on
the internet and Yahoo was one of them a
web portal was a site that internet
users relied on for everything from
searching the web sending emails and
reading the news and Yahoo dominated
with Yahoo search Yahoo mail and Yahoo
news if you own the entry point of the
internet you control the internet and
Yahoo was the biggest web portal beating
out AOL and MSN Yahoo was basically the
Google of the early 2000s speaking of
Google in 1998 Google actually
approached Yahoo to sell their companies
for one million dollars but back then
Google didn't have any users it was only
their page rank algorithm so Yahoo
refused also the way Yahoo's search
worked is it would search its own Yahoo
directories Yahoo basically hand-picked
all the content you need on the internet
organized on their site implementing
Google search would actually get users
off the platform and into other websites
which Yahoo didn't want Yahoo wanted
users to just stay on their platform
they wanted to be the whole internet
but the internet grew and the landscape
was changing you couldn't expect people
to get everything you need on one
platform Google over the years slowly
crept up and became one of the top four
websites by monthly visits since it was
useful by showing relevant search
results they were also insanely
profitable because of their ad model
very soon Google gained the majority of
the search market share Yahoo realizes
his mistake and tries to buy Google for
three billion dollars but Google said no
we want 5 billion and then Yahoo said no
idiot
and that's the beginning of their
downfall Tech moves fast user Behavior
changes and the digital landscape
evolves the way people interact with the
internet in the early 2000s is way
different than in the late 2000s Google
became the internet's entry point who
knew search would be so important
well I guess Google did yeah just like
today we have an idea of how we interact
with the internet using phone apps and
web browsers but we actually have no
idea what that will look like in 10
years that's why it's vital for big tech
companies like Microsoft and Google to
hedge for the future by buying out all
these new tech startups to try to keep
up with the latest advancements it
doesn't get much coverage but Google
invested 1.5 billion dollars in crypto
startups actually look at all these
companies and their blockchain
Investments most of it will not see the
light of day like this one but you need
to have an open mind to survive as a big
company companies are constantly trying
to get ahead there's a higher cost to
not invest in something that might
become the future than to invest in
something that ends up being a failure
Yahoo tried to build their own new
search engine to compete with Google but
they just couldn't keep up they acquired
search engine inkedomi and also ad
Revenue maker Overture but their
execution just wasn't there it's not
that Yahoo is didn't know that acquiring
startups was necessary to stay
competitive and to grow their business
the mistake was not knowing what areas
to invest in for example they paid 5.7
billion dollars for broadcast.com
betting on internet radio and also 3.6
billion dollars for geocities to bet on
user-generated websites if Yahoo would
have invested in Google not even
acquired things might have looked very
different if Yahoo knew that search was
going to be such a big deal a game
changer to the internet they would have
been more proactive in acquiring Google
the hindsight is 2020.
the story of Yahoo continues with a
string of desperate pivots and changes
in leadership and finally ends with
Yahoo selling to Verizon for a measly
4.48 billion dollars today Microsoft and
Google think that the future is AI and
it will transform the way we interact
with the internet that's why they're
trying to move fast on this and even
rushing things with chat GPT getting so
much adoption Google's reputational risk
no longer outweighs the risk of falling
behind which is why they rush to release
Bard it's almost a life or death
situation which brings us back to the AI
War here's the state of the war right
now chat GPT is way ahead of Bard which
didn't even launch yet but I think this
battle is more theatrical more for brand
awareness since I don't see people using
chechi PT much if AI will soon be
integrated in products that we use daily
like search or web browsers Bing is
behind in users but that allows it to
move fast Google is super care with
search since it's their flagship Maker
Now open AI is well funded with 10
billion dollars of Microsoft money and
has momentum and is winning the public
attention Google has the advantage of
its big existing user base they dominate
in terms of market share for search and
their Chrome web browser GitHub co-pilot
in my opinion has already won the coding
vertical so it's no longer a pawn it's a
rook now I would say Google is not
looking so good right now there is a
real risk of losing this race which
would render a lot of Google's products
irrelevant but I'm still cheering for
them since they gave me this free hat
Google is trying really hard to not let
history repeat itself where this time
Google is in Yahoo's position now
they've proven that they can Dethrone
the king but now let's see if they can
defend it all right so that's it for
today thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video